hey everyone and welcome to part five of
building a full stack web application
using view Jas and expressed yes I am
Cody and let's go ahead and get started
so if you remember in the last one we
kind of built up the songs panel and we
made his songs in point to grab all the
songs and a songs in point to post new
songs created this panel to create songs
and all these are required fields so in
this part of the tutorial we want to
continue on and build out the
functionality of viewing a song so if
you remember here when we clicked view
it takes you to this URL which is song
slash ID which is one in this case and
if we were to go back to the routes just
to refresh our memory we have a new
route here called song / song ID and we
have the name as song and the component
is view song so basically that's just
going to show this component here and we
need to start implementing this out so
to start off we can actually grab that
same data from the back end so assuming
that we have it back in endpoint we
could do mounted and then run a function
when it's mounted and then up here again
we're just going to import whatever that
song's thing is that we used so import
song service go ahead and just close out
of these extra tabs and make it easier
to figure out what I'm doing so inside
here we import song service from that
services / song services folder and what
we can do when it mounts is remember to
do a sync we can say Const song is equal
to a wait song service dot I'm gonna say
show and then here I'm going to pass in
a song ID in order to get the song ID
from the URL here so remember this was a
1 and we want to grab it all we need to
do is I say all but there's a lot of
stuff you need to grab so this store dot
state dot route params dot song ID so
there's a lot of stuff going on but
basically this is the
the UX store Lee grab the state in the Z
Buick store route is defined because if
you remember an app a long time ago we
did added this line to sync the router
to the store so whenever the router
changes in the UI that value here route
params that song ID changes as well so
to kind of demonstrate that let's just
go ahead and make sure that we can go to
this page
let's see song services grab I never use
let me just comment this out really
quick print out song ID okay what is
this one worrying about now trailing
space ok so again I was trying to
explain how we can get the song ID from
the URL and to demonstrate that as we
change routes every time in view this
route changed event is being dispatched
so if you remember in if I go back to
the store here we have set user as an
action and set token as an action those
are kind of actions that are dispatched
and it turns out that the view router
what I call the view sink what does it
called again I'm sorry the view X router
sync module is basically just a way to
map and send out dispatch events and
whenever our route changes so if you
look here inside here we can go to route
and at this point the prams or paths or
songs if I were to go to hit the plus it
changed this to a full path of songs and
again I can time travel back to those
states that I want to so very useful but
what I'm trying to explain here is that
as you go to the different routes if
there is a params that'll be declared on
this brands object so if I go back to
here
click view we see here on params we have
song ID of one which is why we get that
very long store state route params song
ID okay now that we have the song ID we
can go ahead and try to grab it from the
back end so let's say song service show
song ID and then if I go to services and
go to song services we can add that show
method here so I'm just gonna say show
song ID and then I'm going to return an
API dot get on songs / song ID so
hopefully that makes sense for everyone
we're basically just passing the song's
ID building up a string so should try to
access song / song ID and again I'm
gonna go ahead and save it
actually so when we get the song back
we'll say this dot song and then up here
we can say data return song of null see
if it lets me save that and it does so
now when we go to the songs in point
I'll just do a hard refresh you can see
that it's making a network request to
song / 1 4 or 4 not found and that's
because again we have not implemented
that in the back end so let's go ahead
and do that part so if we go down here
to songs controller before that go to
route somebody's closed out of all this
we can just make a new route which is a
get request to songs / song ID call the
show method again that's not declared so
I'm going to go ahead and copy paste
this index method here and change it the
show and now what we want to do is
instead of find all we can say find by
ID and we do wrecked out params that
song ID so instead of songs I'll say
song and return that and I think that's
all we need to do let me just double
check yeah I think that's good so now at
this point again it's always good to go
over here just copy that and rename it
to get song and then I could say song of
ID 1 save that now if I do a get request
look at that it returns an object it
returns that some song object back to us
it's not necessary array so what that
means is in our UI at this point if we
were to refresh this page it should
request that song we should get a
response with that entire song awesome
and what we can do now at this point is
go back to the UI
go to that songs view and we can start
building our template to use that song
data attribute right there so to do that
let's just go ahead and create a couple
of panels so again with the include
panel case-sensitive so make sure you do
that right and components make sure you
include panel so what we can do at this
point is basically we can build out a
panel give it a title of song meta data
and then let's go ahead and just test to
make sure we can print out our song so
I'll just say it song title go over here
it's a cold title should be called title
tonight reaper title of null I think in
fact I should just make this an empty
object let me just refresh the page
really quick
hmm
well should be putting in there I'll see
let's try to print out a couple of other
ones
seong service show i mean i could print
out what this that song is at this point
see if that gives us anything in the
console gives us an object with data man
every time i'm sorry so i keep
forgetting that again this is going to
return to data okay so those all showed
up now alright so going back to the view
let's go ahead and actually build out a
couple of different panels so the first
panel i want to build I'll just say wrap
that in a different now and then here
actually I'll say V layout and I go V
flex here and this is because I want to
build again like side by side panel on
the left and a panel on the right and if
I were to go here I simply just put that
here and we should get half screen okay
so very similar to how we did it before
if I go to that songs view let's just go
ahead and copy this code
and maybe we can find a way to like
reuse it if it's something that we find
that we can reuse between components but
I'll go ahead and copy this and I'll
paste this here not sure why the
indentation is off by a little bit
Oh see maybe flexp anyway okay so V Leia
is good now so again this should all
work fine only issue is again we had
like some custom styles over there
and the reason I'm I don't think I'm
gonna build a reusable component between
these two things is because I do think
view songs will change drastically
because they might have different
buttons and whatnot
but for now I'm just gonna copy and
paste those styles into here so that we
have a very similar look as to the other
one and instead of in having view we
don't need a view anymore so I'll just
go ahead and get rid of the view because
we're already on that page right
so underneath I think the album we want
to go ahead and just put the album title
so I can say a song dot album and that
puts it down there probably cuz I just
need to I could just add a break to fix
that but alright so that is the album
title for whatever reason I put it as
bla bla bla but just to show you I think
there's gonna be a lot of different
stuff that's gonna potentially be added
maybe more buttons to like bookmark or
on bookmark to edit or delete it will be
on this panel so let's not go ahead and
try to abstract you know a functionality
for this view and this video let's keep
this one separate so with that being
said I think on the right side so this
is panel on the right actually don't
start you down here this is the panel to
the right what we want to do is just go
ahead and make another panel title can
be tabs and close off that panel and
then aside here we can just say song dot
tab
so we have a tabbed panel now go ahead
and just do a class of margin left to
just to give it a little bit of space
and the tab is not showing up yet and
that could be because the thing we're
getting back has nothing for tab so in
this case I think it'd be useful if we
could have some real data and this is
going back to why you should have real
data it just makes it easier to build up
in application with real data versus you
trying to like figure stuff out so I
think if we go back to bruh ya browse go
to create I'm gonna go ahead and just
try to fill that out more so float on
artist modest mouse genre rock album and
that's going to be good news for people
who love bad news go ahead and copy this
YouTube ID keep that intact so now here
I can say float on Guitar Tabs let's
just find a legit tab I don't care if
it's even that good but basically I'm
just gonna copy this
and paste it in here and honestly this I
mean I want to be doing this in a real
live app because I'm not just gonna copy
someone else's guitar tab probably have
like my own Terms of Service and Privacy
Policy and require people to upload
their own but this isn't even plan to be
going live so unless someone else wants
to grab my repo and do something with it
feel free to so we have the guitar tab
and float on we can say song lyrics you
know Google's pretty good at just giving
us the lyrics right here so thanks
Google so I'll go add the lyrics I'll go
create song that gets us back a song
down here so I d6 is the good one that
has all the good data so one thing
you'll notice is on the tabs thing this
is all like messed up so order to
inspect the element here
I wonder if that's just because it's
it's inside of a div I think I just need
that inside a text area
so anyway going back to create song
let's go ahead and take the similar text
field that we use for the tab so I'll go
here I'll go to view song and instead of
just doing song tab I will put the text
field and have it point to song this was
not going to be required nor do we need
the rules
actually in fact let's just change this
the text area
change it to read-only and then change
it to be model oh we already have be
modeled there so I'll just say text area
because we don't want some extra styles
on there so we have a text area now and
I think it'd be useful if we made this
like close to full width so down here I
can say text area with is 80% see if
that works okay so we do have a text
area now with the width so I don't like
how you can collapse it and stuff so
first of all I'm gonna say font family
motto space we could do with of 80%
border:none height of 600 pixels or Sal
nun border-color:transparent
overflow:auto so it's a scroll bar and
then padding of 20 pixels do 40 pixels
all right so at this point I'm just
gonna do 100% why not cool so we have
the tabs here that was pretty easy to do
going back to a review song if we were
to add yet another V flex or I'm sorry
you could do a beat layout and earn eat
that so go ahead and make another video
out and inside here we're gonna do a
very similar thing so boom there's
there's a lot of copy-paste going on
here so I think at this point or soon
I'm going to refactor this to have
nested files to represent all the
different panels but for right now we
don't need song metadata here this is
probably going to be like a YouTube
embedded but here over on the right
SUV layout
I think I accidentally deleted something
that I shouldn't have let's see I think
I'll just take the view layout and put
it down here okay the issue is I don't
have a route so I need to add in all
that and make that a little bit smaller
so instead of tabs we can say lyrics
over here you just do song lyrics we go
ahead and save that see what it gives us
in fact I think we should make the
YouTube video go up here and there right
so that lyrics and songs are right next
to each other so I'm going to pull that
out
hold on
okay let's see B flex here alright so at
at this point I'm feeling this page is
getting a little bit more complicated
than I like it too so it's good if we
can kind of split up a view into smaller
views so again at components I'm just
going to go ahead and create a view song
folder and I'm just gonna cut that and
put it into the view song folder whoops
not sure why I did that
anybody's click-and-drag yeah there you
go
so inside viewed song I'm gonna go ahead
and say song meta data that view and
that is going to be pretty much all of
the stuff that is here I'm just gonna
put the song metadata here in this file
and what we can do here is just go ahead
and pass down the props of song because
we don't want all these different
smaller panels to also make HTTP
requests they get that song using the
song ID and I'm sure there's stuff you
can do like cash on your service or you
could just use your view X date and just
have you know song somewhere on the
state but for now I'm just going to have
the props
oops should be an array I've been but
pretty much just clear props in passing
song so inside here all these should
have access to song so if I were to save
song metadata now and go back to view
song I should be able to say song at
data and then for props I'm gonna bind
song equal to song and I'm gonna go
ahead and close out of all this or not
close out but you know delete
then I think that's good if I were to
save this let's see let me just go ahead
and come with this stuff out for now
those are just file or directory' okay
so that's because we did not change it
in our router so up here we can go to
components use song and then / view song
and maybe we should rename this as
something else instead of view song
maybe like index that view I don't know
if you guys have a different approach to
that feel free to let me know but so
instead we can just do yeah view song
index
seong metadata is not registered okay so
at this point we can go back here and
make sure we import import saw metadata
from slash components slash song
meta data and of course we need to put
that down in the components here save
this file and it should show up oh I
forgot to put you song so the difference
between this @ symbol this is like
absolute path we could just do a
relative path if we wanted to in this
case it might make more sense addition
to a relative path to the folder because
we know these are all kind of sub
components of view song so instead I'll
just do that alright so now we have a
panel which is being displayed um
actually panels not being displayed
because I forgot to include it over here
so again what we can do is go back to
the index we can go and grab this panel
here and import it and then say
components panel alright so now we have
a panel and again that image is gigantic
but if you remember here in the index of
view we have like all this style to find
and it's not even relative or it's not
even relevant to the index in general
it's more relative to that song metadata
so what we can do is just put it in here
instead of inside of that other thing so
go ahead and just delete all that so
then it makes it really easy to know
okay if we're looking at this main view
song index the only thing that's
relative is this text area style which
we're probably going to abstract later
on so now we go back in our song
metadata panel is being displayed
perfectly and it's all nested inside the
song metadata sub view
so then we probably want to also create
something similar to the the panel but
for YouTube videos so say YouTube view
I'll just say YouTube why not
so then in YouTube if we can come over
here and just say use something called
you'd to and again I don't yeah we do
need the pass the song to it but in this
case it may make more mate sorry it
might make more sense to just pass the
YouTube ID which in fact if we were to
go to YouTube now we can save props it's
going to be in YouTube ID
and go ahead and remember to install
components panel I probably should is
copied and pasted a copy of this because
it's very similar so if I were to go
back to the YouTube view and just go
ahead and copy that into here what we
could do at this point is just say panel
title equals YouTube video close the
panel and then for now I'll just say
YouTube ID because we're going to import
another YouTube module to be able to
actually display that I think I actually
need to include it here in the index so
if I were to import u-tube then go down
here and paste YouTube here go back we
get a YouTube panel and it prints out
that YouTube ID so again for YouTube
video let me just add a little bit of
margin left to just so it's not so
adjacent to that other one but so we
actually want to display this YouTube
video right an embedded YouTube player
so if we were to go and just do a Google
search for view YouTube component we can
see that there's a couple and github so
let's just go ahead and check out this
one here hundred thirteen stars so
basically they say all I need to do is
MPM install it so if I were to go back
to my client thing and install view
YouTube embedded and then I go to my
main go ahead and include it it's just
nice to just copy and paste code so
close here I'll go to main go just paste
all that and we don't need view we do
need that we if you don't want to
install the component globally I do not
want it globally actually well
yeah I don't really want to globally so
I'll just put this down here save this
and then we can go back make sure that
the downloads done it looks like it is
go back there Docs what else do they say
and they say we could just do something
like this
so at this point we can actually go to
our YouTube whatever this component was
instead of just putting YouTube out here
we can say use YouTube and then we want
to pass it a couple of attributes so one
is video ID and that's going to be song
ID our YouTube ID like we're passing it
in the props and then we do a player
width is 50 or 500 pixels player height
is 194 not sure why that's arbitrary
let's do 200 and then get rid of that so
now I think if we wanted to use that you
know I'll just I'll just include it
globally for now I think well let's see
if we could just require it so I'll
first import it here so import it I'll
go to components and hopefully that will
just work
uh let's see unless you have to even
their docks they tell you how to not
include it globally
all right just for brevity I'm just
gonna go back and include a couple
globally actually I just kind of bother
me I want to figure out why this isn't
working so if I go back to YouTube view
and import this and try to import that
and just say YouTube see if that works
nope all right scratch all that I'm just
gonna go back here and include it
globally for now so if someone has any
information about how to actually just
include that in my one little view feel
free to leave me some feedback but in
the meantime we got the embedded player
working here I'm gonna go back and just
make it a little bit larger so if I go
to go back to YouTube
make the width like 800 height 400 yeah
it's too big
cool so that's good enough for now I
mean I could spend more time making this
perfect or just setting both these
panels to a fixed height but for the
next part we need to display the lyrics
and the so you gotta I should play it
over here pretty cool but anyway it I
can go back and let's make some more
views for the lyrics in the tab so here
I'll just say lyrics dot view and that's
gonna have just copy and paste for one
of these get rid of all this scope stuff
go back to index I think we do need this
text area so go back the lyrics base
that in here and get rid of all that and
now to display those could just do a
panel over here and assuming that song
is passed in and panels already declared
if we save this I think this should work
well hold on we have to first do this
let me just delete all that stuff and
here of course we need to include it
first so I'm gonna say lyrics and then
in components we're gonna go and include
lyrics and then lastly we need to
actually use it so lyrics and of course
it required a property called song so
I'm going to pass down
to that and let's just save that and see
what happens okay we got the lyrics
printed out down here awesome
make sure you can't minimize it and I
think this is all settings like a
marking top of two it's really close to
the bottom panel there cool
and then lastly we should build another
sub component for the tab so I'm just
gonna do the same thing copy/paste
lyrics rename two tabs I think you just
tab and then here tab tab make sure
everything's good save that cannot
include tab from tab what does it say
import tab from slash to tab tab is
defined but is never used okay never
used it in component cool so now I have
a tab section over here and again we
need to add a little bit of margin top
to that the fact I could just add it to
this I think that's be done with it so
because this is row two
this is Row one go up here nice alright
so now we have let me just refresh this
completely we have a view for viewing
all the songs we have a view for
creating songs we have a view for
viewing the tabs and the lyrics on that
song we can play the YouTube video over
here and it'll display a couple of stuff
on to the left
okay so again I think the most important
thing to recap on is first of all
including an external module that I've
like I didn't make someone else made and
by simply just following their
instructions by installing it
Estonia globally
or you don't have to do it globally
extra I should look into how to actually
figure this out or if they're not war
and it's just copying pasting that into
your project to tell you what props you
need to use what methods that you can
listen to and that's about it
so basically viewing their Docs I was
able to install it and quickly bring it
into my project by following their
instructions and that was kind of just
to demonstrate how typically easy it is
to kind of build pick-and-choose
components from NPM and I think the
second thing I should highlight is I'm
not sure if this approach is the best
but basically if you're one page or
state or route if you're one route is
starting to become really unmanageable I
think it's a good idea to split it up
into sub components as much as possible
because if you saw before that index
file was getting really large and like
is getting like impossible to actually
find what I was looking for so instead
if I just pull it out into these four
sub components kind of makes life easier
for me and then again each one of these
sub components knows exactly what it's
concerned about so this one is just
concerned about fetching the song this
one is just concerned about rendering
the lyrics this one is just concerned
about the metadata so it makes it a lot
easier to follow the code
so at this point I think it's useful if
we create yet another page where we can
edit a existing song so for now I'm just
gonna copy the create song page and
rename it to edit song view and
typically if you notice the structure I
have this kind of a flat flat looking
structure where every file here should
be something that points to a route
except for you know a couple of them
like panel which could go into a commons
folder I believe you might refactor that
in a second but for now for create song
it's gonna be very very similar to edit
song if not identical except for like a
couple of changes but let's first go to
our router and again let's include it so
edits song I think I've shown you create
song a second ago but edit song here and
that's going to be component slash edit
song and then I can add a new path to
the router here and say song / song ID /
edit and I could say songs song / edit
change that's the edit song go ahead and
save that it'll be nice to have a way to
get to that page instead of having to
just change the URL so let me just close
this tab mayham up here I've way to me
tabs open just take a little five-second
breather alright so we can go back to
our I've known patient was on his view
song and then our view metadata or song
metadata let's go ahead and try to add
in a button so that we can edit the song
when we want to and we could add that in
to like something here so I'll say I'm
just going to grab a button from
something we know so like songs probably
has B button if we don't want the fab
button over here
go ahead and just paste that in here
song
edit Bram's the song ID navigate to know
maybe there's a way to like define a
global so I just do this in a global
state so but in the meantime I'm just
gonna go ahead and just do it this way
maybe next part of the video I'll just
refactor that's where you learn a bit a
little bit more about view so now we
have a button called edits and it shows
up here maybe we want to have a B at the
bottom I think we can just add bottom
here and it'll just put it to the bottom
no maybe not but anyway we can style
this later I don't want to waste too
much time on styling because that is
what eats up most of the time but now
when we click this edit button we go to
songs / 6 / edit and for whatever reason
it loaded in no data so let me just
clear that and refresh the browser just
to make sure okay so it's not gonna load
data because we are in a edit song view
and we haven't really loaded any data
like this was expected to be blank and
then we're creating the data so instead
let's just go ahead and do a show and
then again with that that route pram
that we needed if we go back to view
song and just go ahead and copy these
two this is a great example of what we
need to do so inside the trycatch grab
the song ID grab the song's data and we
can just go ahead and close all that out
go back to this page and I don't think
anything is pointy
let's see song this top song maybe make
sure this is printing out correctly oh
wait it's cuz I have this in the wrong
method so now I actually want a mounted
call so instead of or in addition to
methods we want mounted and then we want
to call something and do some logic
whenever this component is melting and
let's just go ahead and fetch that song
and put it on to this dot song and then
instead of create maybe we should do
save so save song hey watch the save
song do it should probably do all the
same logic make sure every field is
filled in and if it is we can just call
put and also probably redirect the user
to something else so let's go ahead and
do that as well and I think a good
example would be great song or we do
router that push yeah
again close out of these I'm only
concerned about edit song at this point
so once we fetch or put the song ID
which again definitely wrap that in a
try-catch
we just want to redirect the user to the
the song that he was on previously I'm
sure there's a way to do a router dot
back or something like that but I'm just
gonna do prams song ID song ID this song
and I don't think we need to worry about
this we don't we can implement this in a
second alright so it's giving us an
error here at saying song ID is not
defined and it's not so I think we
actually need to bring in this year I
say the song ID there so we can actually
go back to the song trailing space is
not allowed on one thirteen trailing
space is not allowed on what line is
that
135 okay
all right so now we're on edit song it
fetched all the information for that
song and we can probably change stuff as
needed put an exclamation mark at the
end up with that and if we click save it
should not do anything because I don't
think we have anything really
implemented ready to go
alright so save song when clicked should
be calling the save over here and we
have a method called save let me just
make sure that this is being invoked
yeah save clicked it's saying put is not
a function so that makes sense we
haven't implemented this put yet so if
we go to our services and go to song
service again we're going to have to add
a put and basically this is for updating
so we're also gonna have to do / song ID
so if I do something like that
make sure I using the right back tix
basically this will push that song
payload to that song endpoint which
doesn't a stick exist so let's go ahead
and close out of these things and go to
our routes and copy this one do a put do
it on a song ID in fact I think we can
just do that's fine so I'll make the put
right next to the get so it makes a
little bit more sense
so this is gonna call exons controllers
output method if I go to my songs
controller just here lastly we'd have to
make a put method here oops
so I say put and now what we want to do
here is just go ahead and call update
rec body and then for the second
parameter argument we pass in we only
want to update where the ID was equal to
song ID number song ID is going to be
inside that routes here so we're gonna
grab it and only update the song which
was or which matches that song ID and
then if this works it should just return
that song in fact I think this will
return it's something that we don't want
to sell just going to return this top
body so it's gonna return the same song
you uploaded so I do break down why do
you sort about them and if it doesn't
he'll say an error has occurred trying
to update the song
all right so hopefully let's see what
happens when we do this call a save song
it does a it did a let's see put on song
/ 6 it pasted this information and then
it redirected us 2/6 you know I'm not
sure if it actually edited or updated it
so let's let's make sure the payload
that got sent was an updated title and
it wasn't so if I go back to here and
just add an exclamation mark hit save we
see that updated the song and it added a
commission mark and it actually hit the
back end over here and updated the
database with that data alright so I
think that may wrap it up for part 5
stay tuned for part 6 where I'm probably
gonna add a search component here and
restyle this page just a little bit more
and then I think finally we could wrap
this up in a part 7 or part 8 alright
again thanks for watching and be sure to
subscribe to my Twitter which is in the
description below if you want updates
when the next parts are released
alright see you